a
[Música]
sí
hoy quiero que comiencen embarcándose en
un viaje hacia el pasado conmigo quiero
que se imaginen a una niña de nueve años
pequeña
asustada
se levanta de madrugada porque le falta
el aire
otra crisis de asma
mamá llama a la ambulancia
la niña mira dibujos animados mientras
los médicos la nebulizar
quien lo acompaña en las madrugadas
mama
papá está trabajando
papá está de viaje
crecí con un papá que tuvo que trabajar
mucho que tuvo que perderse en momentos
muy importantes en mi infancia
viajes constantes idas y vueltas
despedidas y saludos
pero ahora ahora quiero que se imaginen
a esa misma niña de 9 años mirando
partidos de fútbol y carreras de fórmula
1 con su papá
el viajaba mucho pero cuando estaba se
encargaba de crear un momento que para
mí era solo mío y de él la pasión por
estos deportes
las idas al estadio las despertadas a
las 4 de la mañana para ver los partidos
del mundial de corea del sur y
japón-2002 las infinitas conversaciones
sobre la rivalidad entre michael
schumacher y rubens barrichelo y los
miles de carritos rojos de ferrari que
él traía a casa
falleció hace tres años pero los
partidos de fútbol y las carreras de
fórmula 1 siguen siendo vistas con la
misma pasión y el mismo deseo como
cuando estaba vivo
porque a quien más le vendieron la idea
de que la maternidad y la paternidad
tenía que ser perfecta para ser buena a
quien más le vendieron la idea de que
teníamos que estar contentos felices
sintiéndonos realizados y presentes las
24 horas al día
comprender que existen diversas formas
de vincularnos con nuestros hijos y que
tanto mamá como papá aportan y cumple un
rol trascendental en la crianza me toma
un tiempo soy psicoterapeuta y psicóloga
perinatal y antes de embarcarme en este
viaje de descubrimiento pensaba las
madres como estos seres omnipotentes
perfectos que todo lo pueden que todo lo
saben y con una sonrisa en la cara
siempre iu a los padres pues como
meramente acompañantes o como en muchos
casos el sustento económico de la
familia
ya sea por mi propia experiencia o
porque eso es lo que la sociedad nos va
enseñando y mostrando
porque al final de cuentas todos tenemos
en la mente este ideal de maternidad
perfecta de estas madres maravillosas
que todos lo saben y todo lo logran que
nunca se quejan y que hoy en día tienen
que cumplir con un check list infinito
de cosas en términos de crianza
un checklist que todos sabemos que es
humanamente posible de cumplir
así que cuando no logró cumplir con
todas estas demandas que la sociedad me
impone llega la fiel compañera de la
maternidad y la paternidad
la culpa la culpa por conectarme con la
realidad y por dejar atrás esa fantasía
de madre perfecta el miedo y el susto al
darme cuenta que a veces me canso
de que a veces me aburro de que a veces
me abrumó
de que a veces no me provoca jugar con
mis hijos
de que a veces pierdo la paciencia
o de que a veces mis hijos me generan
muchas emociones más allá de sólo
felicidad y ilusión
así que la maternidad y la paternidad
más allá de ser solo color de rosa se
parecen más a una montaña rusa de
emociones a una montaña rusa de momentos
llenos de felicidad pero otros un tanto
más duros
cuando mi bebé llora y yo no sé por qué
y no logro descifrarlo
me asusto
me canso
a veces quiero salir corriendo me dice
una mamá
será que soy una mala madre
será que no nací para hacer esto a veces
siento que todos esperan que las madres
y los padres sepamos todo y yo a veces
no sé lo que le pasa a mi bebé
en qué momento nos pusimos la vara tan
alta en qué momento comenzamos a esperar
tanta perfección de los padres
al igual que esa madre existen
muchísimas madres más y muchísimos
padres dudando de sus habilidades
cuestionándose si nacieron para hacer
esto o no
y la realidad es que nadie nace sabiendo
ser padres y que el vínculo con nuestros
bebés los construimos día a día a través
del tiempo y a través de las
experiencias del día a día pero claro
para que estas madres y padres puedan
criar desde su propia humanidad
necesitamos a una sociedad que sea más
empática con las madres y los padres
necesitamos una sociedad que acompañe a
una sociedad que guíe y no a una que
señale apunte juzgue y critique
constantemente a los padres por todas
sus decisiones
yo a veces me pregunto por qué no le
decimos más a menudo a los padres el
buen trabajo que están haciendo
porque nadie nos recuerda que para
cambiar el mundo tenemos que acompañar
más a las madres ya los padres
ellos se encuentran actualmente criando
y creando el futuro de nuestra sociedad
ellos están actualmente criando a los
futuros líderes del mundo
james heckman doctor en la economía de
la mano de psicólogos y neurocientíficos
encontró que el desarrollo infantil
influye directamente en los resultados
económicos sociales y de educación de un
país
su estudio llega para recordarnos que
desde el nacimiento hasta los 5 años de
edad el cerebro del ser humano se
encuentre en un momento crítico que su
velocidad de crecimiento
sobrepasa cualquier otra etapa de
nuestras vidas
qué significa eso pues que todo lo que
ocurre en esta etapa va a jugar un rol
trascendental en el futuro de ese ser
humano que es en esa etapa en donde se
desarrolla la base para las habilidades
cognitivas
sociales y emocionales
así que si es momento de que comenzamos
a invertir un poco más en la salud
mental y en el desarrollo cognitivo de
nuestros bebés y niños
es el primer paso para un cambio a largo
plazo del mundo
o sea que a menudo nos olvidamos de
decirle a los padres es que está
permitido fallar
si está permitido fallar está permitido
equivocarse está permitido aprender y
mejorar
porque el mejor ejemplo para nuestros
hijos que tener a padres que son
conscientes de sus errores y que se
disculpan por ellos porque a la hora de
la hora uno no aprende a disculparse
porque te dicen que lo hagas uno aprende
a disculparse del ejemplo de haber
transitado experiencias con mi madre con
mi padre en donde ellos se hayan
equivocado y se hayan disculpado
normalicemos que los bebés y los niños
se equivoquen normalicemos que es un
vaso de agua se cae en vez de llamar la
atención porque no focalizar nuestra
atención en mostrarle que podemos ir a
la cocina podemos un baño y
limpiar el agua que se cayó
normalicemos que si un adorno se cae no
solo lo botamos a la basura
podemos pegamento y volverlo a
pegar
a pesar de que no lo vayas a volver a
usar nunca más
porque a la hora de la hora está
sensación de que me puedo equivocar y
puedo mejorar y puedo reparar trae una
sensación de bienestar
inimaginable
pero qué difícil no
porque estos bebés y niños llegan a este
mundo enseñarnos las lecciones más
difíciles
porque eso que hace mi hijo me genera
tanto
porque su pataleta su desborde emocional
me moviliza tanto
que sentimos realmente cuando estamos
con cada uno de ellos
estas preguntas
nos permiten y abren un mundo de
preguntas
como acompañaron mi propio desborde
emocional o mi propio pataleta cuando
era niño
como me enseñaron a mí a seguir las
reglas porque al final de cuentas todas
estas experiencias nuevas que vivimos
con nuestros hijos están constantemente
siendo tocadas y revistas por nuestras
propias experiencias de niños si yo les
pregunto que estaban haciendo el día del
atentado de las torres gemelas del 11 de
septiembre
probablemente muchos de ustedes
rápidamente tengan esa respuesta o si yo
les pregunto que se acuerdan del
terremoto de pisco del 2007 muchos de
ustedes recordarán que estaban haciendo
o que estaban comiendo o que estaba
pasando en ese exacto momento en donde
comenzó el terremoto
pero si yo les pregunto que hicieron el
día anterior a ese los que comieron un
lunes hace tres semanas
probablemente recordaré eso sea mucho
más difícil porque porque nuestro
cerebro está hecho para recordar esos
momentos esos momentos que están
asociados a una emoción
cualquier emoción pero como una emoción
porque los recuerdos no son solamente
una recopilación de hechos idénticos
sino que más bien son ventanas que nos
permiten viajar en el pasado y volver a
revivir aquellos momentos
lo que sabemos hoy en día es que la
relevancia emocional y la intensidad de
un momento son factores clave para que
una huella permanezca a largo plazo en
nuestra mente
son todas estas experiencias pasadas las
que nos ayudan a darle sentido a nuestra
vida el día de hoy
eso significa que nuestro cerebro está
constantemente realizando nuestras
experiencias previas
para darle sentido a nuestro mundo y son
esos recuerdos los que van forjando
nuestra identidad y quiénes somos hoy en
día
qué experiencias le estás dejando a tus
hijos
que experiencias positivas estás
construyendo con ellos
igual de importante como los estás
ayudando a transitar sus experiencias
más difíciles
como transitarse tus experiencias más
difíciles
la resolviste o sientes que necesitas
trabajar en ellas para así poder
acompañar a tus hijos desde un mejor
lugar
es momento de sentirnos humanos en la
crianza
porque nuestros hijos nos necesitan así
humanos
qué experiencias estás viviendo que son
solo tuyas y de ellos
que cada vez que tu hijo de un partido
de fútbol una carrera de fórmula uno
una banca en el parque un restaurante en
específico o un programa de televisión
viva y reviva una y otra vez eso que
sintió
contigo y solo contigo porque como miami
eeuu decía la gente olvidara lo que
hiciste
olvidara lo que le dijiste pero nunca
olvidará como la hiciste sentir
gracias
[Música]